okay well thank you so much and now on
the main stage of the Munich security
conference the prime minister of the UK
vicious honak prime minister
[Applause]
the United Kingdom will always be on the
side of Freedom democracy and the rule
of law
and the security of our European
continent will always be our overriding
priority now there's no greater example
of those commitments than our response
to the war in Ukraine
just this year we became the first
country in the world to provide tanks to
Ukraine and the first to train pilots
and Marines
we gave 2.3 billion pounds last year and
we will match or exceed that in 2023 now
other allies can tell a similar story
and our Collective efforts are making a
difference
but with every day that passes
Russian forces inflict yet more pain and
suffering
now the only way to change that
it's for Ukraine to win
[Applause]
so we need a military strategy for
Ukraine to gain a decisive advantage on
the battlefield to win the war and a
political strategy to win the peace
to win the war Ukraine needs more
artillery armored vehicles and air
defense so now is the moment to double
down on our military support
when Putin started this war he gambled
that our resolve would falter
even now he is betting that we will lose
our nerve
but we proved him wrong then and we will
prove him wrong now
together we're delivering as much
equipment in the next few months as in
the whole of 2022.
and together we must help Ukraine to
Shield its cities from Russian bombs and
Iranian drones
and that's why the United Kingdom will
be the first country to provide Ukraine
with longer range weapons and it's why
we're working with our allies to give
Ukraine the most advanced air defense
systems and build the Air Force they
need to defend their Nation now of
course the United Kingdom stands ready
to help any country provide planes that
Ukraine can use today
but we must also train Ukrainian Pilots
to use the most advanced Jets and that's
exactly what Britain is doing so that
Ukraine has the capability to defend its
security for the long term
but to win the peace we also need to
rebuild the international order on which
our collective security depends
first that means upholding international
law
the whole world must hold Russia to
account
we must see Justice
through the ICC for their sickening war
crimes committed
whether in butcher Urban Mario Pole or
Beyond
and Russia must also be held to account
for the terrible destruction it has
inflicted
we are hosting the Ukraine recovery
conference in London this June and we
should consider together how to ensure
that Russia pays towards that
reconstruction
now second the treaties and agreements
of the post-cold War era have failed
Ukraine
so we need a new framework for its
long-term security
from human rights to Reckless nuclear
threats from Georgia to Moldova Russia
has committed violation after violation
against countries outside the collective
security of NATO
and the international community's
response has not been strong enough
as the end stoltenberg has said Ukraine
will become a member of NATO but until
that happens we need to do more to
bolster Ukraine's long-term security
we must give them the advanced NATO
standard capabilities that they need for
the future
astray that will remain by their side
willing and able to help them defend
their country again and again
Ukraine needs and deserves assurances of
that support So ahead of the NATO Summit
in Vilnius we will bring together our
friends and allies to begin building
those long-term assurances and our aim
should be to forge a new Charter in
Vilnius to help protect Ukraine from
future Russian aggression
now let me conclude with one final
thought
what's at stake in this war
is even greater than the security and
sovereignty of one nation
it's about the security and sovereignty
of every nation
such as Invasion it's abhorrent war
crimes and irresponsible nuclear
rhetoric are symptomatic of a broader
threat to everything we believe in
from the Skies over North America
to the suffering on the streets of
Tehran
some would destabilize the order that
has preserved peace and stability for 80
years
they must not Prevail and we need not be
daunted as president zielinski said when
he addressed the UK Parliament last week
we are Marching towards the most
important victory of our lifetime
it will be a victory over the very idea
of War
and we could have no greater purpose
than to prove him right thank you
prime minister thank you uh your speech
I thought was very clear basically
Ukraine has to win the war in Russia
loses but you said something I want to
pick up on and elaborate you talk about
need to assurances for Ukraine what does
that mean specifically and when do you
do them do you do them while the war is
still ongoing don't you fear that Russia
will say ultimately we're right we don't
fight Ukraine we fight NATO well uh
really nice to see you I think first of
all it's it's clear that the security
guarantees the architecture that was in
place before this war has failed Ukraine
right that's just a statement of fact uh
Ukraine had received assurances when it
gave weapons up Russia is continually
violated whether it's human rights
treaties or indeed Arms Control treaties
so what happened before has not worked
so we should be clear about that and now
our job is to look forward and say
what's the right thing going forward now
as I mentioned against altenberger said
NATO you know or Ukraine will be a
member of NATO but between now and then
what I think we need to work on are
providing Ukraine with the means to win
the war right now and that means very
specifically artillery long-range
weapons armored vehicles
air defense that's the most critical
thing what we can also do is make sure
that we're training Ukraine on NATO
standard equipment that's what we're
doing when it comes to aircraft with
their pilots but I think what we do need
to do is think about the future of how
we protect Ukraine security and we need
to have that conversation with our
allies and talk about the longer term
provision of supporting Ukraine and
that's the conversation that I think we
should start having because the Vilnius
Summit is a good place to conclude that
so this year so the insurances would
come this year I wonder there has been a
lot of debate you talked about the
fighter jets there has been a lot of
debate here about the ammunition the
risk that they may not have enough
ammunition but also the long range Miss
house is concerned that perhaps one of
the targets would be Crimea under your
watch as UK prime minister would you
approve of long-range missiles that
could hit Crimea I think I think the
most important thing here to recognize
is it actually starts with NATO what is
NATO is a defensive Alliance right
that's the first thing to recall what is
Ukraine doing Ukraine is trying to
defend itself right it is suffering
unprovoked aggression it's territorial
Integrity its sovereignty has been
violated
its people are being killed
and it has every right to defend itself
and that's what we should be doing and
that's the support that we collectively
in this room are providing and
critically there are things that Ukraine
needs to gain that decisive advantage on
the battlefield that's why the provision
of heavy tanks was so important it's why
air defense is absolutely critical
you're right to mention artillery and
long-range weapons also help now those
are all the things that will allow
Ukraine to defend itself and repel
Russian aggression and indeed yes to
have a counter-offensive that moves
Russia outside of its own country I
think that's entirely reasonable and we
should be fully behind Ukraine in that
ambition and want that ambition to
succeed and for them the entire country
means crime is you know uh very well
in your speech there was a lot of
Bravada in the sense of Ukraine has to
win the war in Russia has to be proven
wrong Vladimir Putin has to lose this
war some would say you make it clear you
still believe the UK is a big
geopolitical agent zolenski obviously
went to London he sees value in the UK
but some here would believe to really be
the strong geopolitical agent you need
to solve the pending issues that you
have with the EU I know you probably
know this question is coming there's a
frenzy of reports that you do have a
deal over the northern Irish protocol
that could come Monday potentially do
you have a deal does it come Monday and
I wonder beyond that it doesn't reflect
your wish that you want to have a normal
working relationship with your European
allies so
lots of things in there to unpack I
think that the first thing to say when
it comes to the issue of the Northern
Ireland protocol there are real issues
that need resolving the way that the
protocol has been implemented it's
causing very real challenges for
families for people for businesses on
the ground very practical difficulties
and they need to be resolved but also
there's an issue of the democratic
deficit that sits at the heart of the
protocol as it's currently constructed
now those are the things that we need to
resolve and
I'm working very hard together with my
ministerial colleagues foreign
secretaries in the audience Secretary of
State for Northern Ireland you know we
are working very closely together we're
engaging in those conversations with the
European Union next week potential all
the time and we have been for a while
but what I'd say is there is still work
to do I think there is still work to do
there are still challenges to work
through we have not resolved all these
issues no there is no there isn't a deal
that has been done that there is an
understanding of what needs to be done
it's the issues that I outlined and
James was in Brussels yesterday I've
been in Northern Ireland talking to
parties there about the things that we
need to fix we're working through those
we're working through them hard and we
will work through them intensely with
the EU but we are by no means done there
is no deal that is done that there's
work to do and that's what we all said
about doing